(crunching)
(whining)
(muffled laughter)
(happy music)
- Today, we're here to play
some asian drinking games.
- It is Friday, it is 5 o'clock.
- I have nothing to do
for the rest of the day,
so I'm ready to drink.
- I'm nervous. My hands are clammy.
- Yeah, me too!
- I'm also the world's
most competitive person.
- No competition at all.
- Oh, see that's not true.
- Fun fact, I have to present in front of
my entire team after this video ends.
- One person will walk
out of here the winner.
- The rest of us will be on the floor.
- Let's get right to it.
- Our first game is from
Korea, called Titanic.
- We have beer and soju.
- A beer glass is filled
halfway with beer.
- Put the shot glass in and
we take turns pouring soju in.
Whoever sinks it.
- Has to down the entire soju bomb.
- I'm pumped.
- You're screwed.
(beer can pops open)
- Pour like half
- We need it to float!
- Put the glass in there.
- I'm shaking.
- Is it a magic trick?
- Be gentle. There it is.
- One finger.
(shouting)
- Oh my god. I feel like
David Blaine right now.
- Oh my god.
(nervous laughter)
- Oh my god, I am freaking out.
- It's defying gravity.
- Say goodbye Rose, 'cause
this ship is about to sink.
- Oh no.
- No!
- Bye, Vaughn.
- Cheers, y'all.
- Remember, if you sink it you have
to drink the entire thing.
- I get it, I get it.
(gasps)
Sara did it, Sara did it.
- Seven, six, five.
- The goal is not for me to choke.
- But it is to burp really
loud when you're done.
(burps)
- So the next game is from
China, called finger guessing.
- Shooting out a certain number of fingers
while simultaneously saying a number
between zero and however many
fingers are participating.
- Whoever guesses the exact amount
or closest wins, and the
other two must drink.
- So we're shouting and
fingering at the same time.
- You get it?
- No.
When you guys are involving numbers
and alcohol, already I'm
fucked in this situation.
- Let's get to fingering.
- Three, two, one.
(all shout out numbers)
- We have 21. I said ten.
- I said 30. I said 30.
- So you win.
- Gan Bei!
- I won, I won!
- I always forget.
- Three, two, one.
(all shout out numbers)
- I said 22.
- 11.
- Um, what?
- Everyone just has to drink.
- Wow, guys. That is
a very stressful game.
- It's a lot of coordination.
You have to like,
hold up a different number
than what you're saying.
- Cheers. That was a little embarrassing.
- To being really bad at this game.
- Next up.
- From Japan.
- Is.
- The Pocky game.
- Two people have to nibble away
towards the center of a Pocky.
- A la, Lady and the Tramp.
- And whoever pulls away loses
and you finish your drink.
- This is going to be the
most intimate I've ever gotten
with a coworker, so, hope
you guys brushed your teeth.
- All right, come on, isn't
this getting you excited?
(laughs)
- No.
- Listen, this could take a
turn if you're really drunk.
- This game is how babies are made.
(laughing)
- I'm a fucking champion.
- I wanted to last so much
- That's what he said.
- I've got it down to
like this big before.
(whining)
(laughing)
- Really? I'm so glad I could be
part of this intimate moment.
- Cheers to us.
- We're really close now.
- This experience has changed everything.
- Can I start with my final thoughts?
I have so many final thoughts.
(laughter)
- Sober.
- I feel happy I feel relaxed.
- I'm drunk.
- I'm very excited about all
the games I learned today.
- Brings us together, like
this. Now we're best friends.
- It's not like the math game.
- That was my favorite game.
- I was good at counting.
- I honestly really like the Pocky game,
but like this, it can get sorta weird.
- In these types of games,
the loser is really the winner
because you get to booze it up.
- Drink responsibly though you
know, like drink responsibly.
- I got nervous in the beginning
that I wasn't getting
drunk and then I sped up.
- That being said, do you
want to play Pocky pong?
- Pocky pong.
- Absolutely, 100 percent yes.